[Music]
my name is Morgan McClane I'm a product
manager at Google I in particular I'm
the product manager of our stackdriver
APM software and open census for those
who aren't aware our stackdriver APM
software is composed of stack grabber
trace stack driver debugger and stack
driver profiler I'm gonna talk about
both of those things today so stack
driver and open census i've actually
divided the talk pretty deliberately
into two so we're spending the first
half on stack driver in the second half
on open census open census is an open
source project that we collaborate on
with a number of other vendors so i kind
of wanted to delineate put a nice sort
of separation between these a lot of the
concepts will be the same and certainly
we'll be doing different demonstrations
of both but just keep that in mind as we
go through that the talk is sort of
divided into so like I said we're
starting of part one which is about how
we actually do observability and
optimization troubleshooting for app
development at Google and this ties of
the stack driver so I know the term
observability is being thrown around a
lot at conferences on the internet
everywhere recently you know you can
look back at a number of great talks
like certainly one I think that Adrienne
Cole did a few years ago called
observability three ways where he talked
about tracing logs analysis and metrics
and to be clear that's a really great
way to approach the problem but I
suspect that thinking about
observability in terms of the tools that
we use to analyze it probably isn't
quite as useful as actually talking
about the concepts that we that we want
to talk about and and indeed talking
about what we can actually achieve by
being able to observe how our
application operates so when we think of
Google at Google observability we think
of you know actual scenarios that
engineers have to adapt to every day
right when someone searches for cat
pictures what systems are impacted or
why are some requests low will the
system scale if we get a lot more users
and this is where observability you know
the concepts behind observability give
us a lot of are able to answer these
questions that we have so in practice we
find observability means a couple things
it means setting expectations so you
would have heard I think this morning's
keynote a lot about a SLO or SLI
monitoring and that's what we use at
Google to actually set expectations for
how a service should perform
right we set actual sort of standards
for the latency given a certain amount
of usage should be such the error budget
should be this other thing and so if
you're not able to set those
expectations it becomes difficult when
looking at a services performance to
understand if it's operating as it
should
the next is context so understanding
what a service actually does if you're
an engineer and you work on a service
that's five or ten or even 50 layers
down in the stack you need to understand
those interactions all around often
that's very difficult particularly at
organisations where they don't have an
automated way of understanding how these
services are supposed to interact right
I'm sure we've all worked in
organizations where you might have five
10 20 50 micro services or more where
you'll have someone who doesn't have
that sort of organizational knowledge
come in and spend a lot of time just
understanding like oh I work on this
little component of the e-commerce
system but I don't understand how that
operates of everything else and in order
to debug problems at scale you need that
context
next is status this is probably the most
simple out of these concepts this is
just understanding is my surface up is
it down how is it performing what's the
reason where's consumption look like
what's the current latency and finally
there's one concept that often gets
forgotten that's actually performing
root cause analysis so it's fine to have
the first three things but when you
actually have a problem in production
you need to actually you need to have
the tools available to actually solve
that problem it's fine to know that a
service is down and you know if you
follow the other serf observability
concepts and have great tooling to
understand like which service is dying
but if you don't have the tools to fix
it or understand what in the code is
actually broken
you still haven't solved the problem so
none of this is new right this is part
of it I think a broader journey that
developers have been on for years where
if you look at client app development
whether that's applications for like
desktops or laptops or phones or video
game consoles or whatever there's been a
lot of great tools for this for years
right think of you know stack traces
whenever you have an unhandled exception
running on your Mac or on Windows right
think of local debuggers local profiling
tools all of these has existed for a
long time
where we struggled is actually adapting
these same techniques to distributed
systems development right becomes
because it becomes a lot more difficult
where you can no longer just attach a
debugger to a single system to solve an
issue because that might have impacts on
other users of that system and you know
might not even know what your system
which system you need to attach it to
and so that's really the sort of the the
struggle that a lot of developers have
been going through for the last ten
years as we shift a lot of our computing
workloads from client applications up to
the cloud or up to you know running on
platforms that you might not even be
able to gain much insight into so that
was a bit of a long prologue but you
were promised something about
observability at Google so let's talk
about that so Google runs it pretty
extreme scale all right that shouldn't
be a surprise to anyone and over the
past few decades we've had to invent new
technologies and tools in order to scale
and survive there's a reason that when
your internet connection is flaky people
go to google.com to actually see if the
Internet is up and if it's not if
google.com doesn't respond they tend to
assume that just their network
connection is flaky a lot of this is due
to our platform but and our people but
it's also due to the tools that we have
in order to gain insight and be able to
fix our systems so I'm gonna start by
just giving you a very brief
introduction to the services available
at Google and the platform so you've
probably heard about things like borg
borg is our container scheduling or
container orchestration service this is
basically what kubernetes is based on
and certainly you know what Google you
may have heard of things like stubby
this is effectively internalized version
of G RPC and some other other tools and
then storage services like spanner
BigTable and others the layer that we've
talked about a lot less is for our
instrumentation and tooling so for
instrumentation all services at Google
are cemented with something called
census these are a set of libraries that
are baked into stubby and baked into
some of our other technologies that
automatically captured traces and app
level metrics for an application so
you'll get distributed traces much like
you would see in stackdriver trace
through a back-end that we called a per
C there but you'll also get metrics for
things like application latency the
queue length of certain are PCs and so
on and you get this as a developer
server for free out of the box you
create a new service census is already
there already capturing this and it for
profiling we have tools like Google wide
profiling and peopre off that capture
information and we've also got like a
production debugger called the Borg
debugger and so we've we've made a lot
of investments in instrumentation to
ensure that when you build a service
inside of Google you get all this
automated for free you don't have to go
reinvent the wheel every time indeed you
typically don't even need to add a
library just work
out-of-the-box it's really nice for
tooling and sort of analysis of this
data we have a number of other backends
so monarch is where we capture in
aggregate stats and analyze them gaffur
which I mentioned before was our is our
distributed tracing system we have P
prof for profiling and like I mentioned
before we have a Borg debugger and I'm
showing you this because in a few
minutes we're going to talk about the
external story and you know we're gonna
replace a lot of these with technologies
you know and some that you might not so
let's talk about how we walk through a
scenario Google for example reducing the
latency of an application so the first
step is actually understanding if a
service is operating more slowly than
expected so as I mentioned in the
beginning we've SL O's and SL eyes and
basically descriptions of the service
that tell us how we expect it to operate
in production and so at Google to launch
a service you need to define those and
so you can set up alerts to find out
when your application has breached those
barriers the X is triage so if you if
you're trying to analyze latency over
time you need to create in store latency
metrics for all our pcs I talked about
census and and monarch and dapper and
that's how we do that inside of Google
and so that's always running on all
surfaces so you can jump back in time
and actually see how your service is
performing and how that performance may
have degraded or gotten better over time
and then you need to be able to narrow
that down and determine the approximate
cause of latency so at Google you might
have requests that hop through tens or
even maybe thousands of microservices
the first job is just finding out which
you know which layer down the stack is
actually slowing things down generally
at that scale it's unlikely that
everything is slowed down though if it
has that's also an interesting
development so you can use tracing to
actually find out where it's gotten slow
and finally you need to go in and solve
the problem this involves you know
actually deploying code or deploying
configuration and so this is you know
this can be achieved by creating things
like custom trace segments and
annotations and your traces or logs or
continuously profiling your running code
I talked about pre people off before
that's our solution for that the other
major scenario we see is resolving
errors in production so we talked about
latency now this is when you actually
have some kind of error whether that's
an unhandled exception that's causing
you know sporadic problems for a person
or for some of your users to a total
average so the first just like before is
getting notified and it's
latency budgets in this case we've an
error budget right and so just like
those latency just like SLO or SLI
frères will fire fire and alert when
those are not met then you have to
understand you want to be able to do
triage right so jumping into metrics
analysis logs analysis or distributed
tracing to find out the source of your
error right once again we're in that
scenario where you have tens hundreds of
thousands of micro services interacting
you need to find out which one or which
changed to a single service actually
caused that problem and then eventually
you need to you want to go and find out
the actual code that's causing a problem
I fly even debugging at Google is
effectively not really an option you
might not be able to reproduce something
it's very difficult to set up a test
environment for something that involves
like tens or hundreds of thousands of
services that's effectively impossible
and so we needed to invent safe
production debugging and that's the Borg
debugger that I mentioned earlier we
finally have one additional scenario and
this is just generally running to reduce
your cost and optimize code this is one
that you might not hear about as often
at other firms like it might you might
not be but certainly my development
career it's not a scenario that came up
as often but for our users and certainly
at Google when we have you know all
these data centers everywhere chugging
away it's really important that we're
able to reduce the cost of those right
if you think of like being able to
reduce your CPU consumption by 1% 5% 10%
or more at that scale like that's this
is huge amounts of money that you're
saving and it becomes really really
important it's the more your business
grows and so when we want to reduce our
costs there's sort of two ways two ways
we go about it the first is just going
through distributed traces and finding
services that are heavily impacted by
single requests right so if it turns out
that doing a search to you know a Google
search or maybe checking your Gmail or
something goes and hits like you know
tens or thousands of disk spindles or
something like that that might not be
the most well optimized query right if
you have a single small request that's
fanning out across your entire network
and getting grabbing data from various
systems and not things are cached well
that's probably a problem but the next
is actually digging into your services
code so you can also situations where a
single service is performing poorly and
as a result you're needing to scale it
out a lot more widely than you expected
and we've seen this internally as well
as with our customers and in that case
continuous profiling so I talked about a
little bit about P profs before but
continuously profiling other
applications so as an engineer you can
go and look at how the code is actually
executed for that app is really powerful
so you can find out if there's some sort
of contention going on or just at your
burning way more CPU cycles on something
that you think you should and so I just
want to hit on some of these core
concepts again I apologize this in
general this seems a little vague we're
gonna go into a very concrete example in
a few minutes but the core concepts we
have here are SL O's and metrics so
actually setting expectations for
services performance whether that's
latency or errors traces and log
correlations so using distributed traces
or basically being able to map the
context of a request and see that how
that stands out across services both to
reduce those services latency or to find
out where a problem might be might be
caused
and finally continuously debugging and
profiling an application debugging and
profiling in production are less common
concepts I'm sure a number of you have
heard of tracing before certainly I
would expect everyone here knows about
distributed metrics and and certainly
disturbed logs but doing this for
profiling and debugging or rather new
concepts and we've got these in a pretty
nice demo these are things we do at
Google every day so to hit on that point
that I opened with Tracy's logs metrics
profiles everything else these are not
observability these are the tools that
we use to achieve observability the more
of these that you build the more you're
able to actually understand how a series
of systems performs in real life and
also you're able to better able to fix
them certainly the term observability
will be evolving you know like certainly
the four or five tools that I've
introduced here are not gonna be the you
know end state that will be in one or
two or three years from now more and
more will be invented and that's just
gonna add in to people's ability to
observe and debug their running
applications so I've talked a bit about
how we do this at Google and for various
reasons I can't necessarily give you a
live demo of the tools we have inside
the company but what I can do is talk
about the tools that we make available
externally and as of today now that
we've had some recent launches those
actually pretty mapped those map pretty
well between what we make available to
GCP developers or really developers
anywhere and what we have inside the
company so that's what I'm going to
demonstrate so before I do that I gave
you this slide before the tools inside
of Google I'm not gonna show you
those tools outside of Google right so
people here externally are not using
things like Borg you're using kubernetes
you're using containers running on other
container orchestration systems using
virtual machines platform-as-a-service
functions the service for our pcs you're
typically using a mix of HTTP G RPC may
be sidecars like on boy or maybe other
RPC systems for storaged you know when
we talk to customers they use my sequel
MongoDB various hosted options whether
that's datastore or things from other
cloud vendors for instrumentation
there's been a lot of interesting
develop developments in the space
recently certainly there's open census
which we develop and spending the second
half of this talk on four metrics and
traces but there are also existing
systems right like a lot of people here
probably are very familiar fusing
Prometheus for collecting metrics from
their applications and certainly for
just distributed tracing like Zipkin is
incredibly popular and includes its own
client libraries and so we see clients
who are already using those today for
profiling and debugging those are still
a little more unique these are concepts
that I suspect effectively invented at
Google and so our offerings in the space
are relatively unique but we offer those
as well and finally for logs I wrote
fluent D here there's also there's you
know it's obviously a ton of things in
this space and for two length sort of
the crux of this talk we have the tools
that we offer so for metrics we stack
driver monitoring which people will be
pretty familiar with the startup
acquired by Google a number of years ago
and it's how we it's the brand we use
for our monitoring software we also
offer stack driver trace profiler
debugger stack driver logging which
completes that sort of those
observability that list of observable
observability tools that exist at Google
except now they're available to our
customers so I'm gonna skip all the way
to the demo so we have here an
application called hipster shop so
anyone who went to the keynote this
morning would have seen this for the
ISTE okie no it's this demo app that
we've created to show off various GCP
features and it emulates an e-commerce
system it's written across eight
separate services I think three or four
of which are written and go two of which
are written in Python
two or three are written in node.js and
one of them is written in dotnet core
they're all running on kubernetes in
fact they're running on gke
there's no sort of special sauce here
this is using stuff that's been
available you know for the last year or
so
hipster shop this version of hips our
shop unlike the one that you saw this
morning is really slow we did a bit of
work to it we ensured that it takes
basically forever to load a page and
even once you load it when you add in
kind of item to your cart it is
unbearably slow and this is a great
example of you know in a web application
where if you ship this and told people
to go buy stuff here you'd be losing a
ton of your customers right off the bat
because it's just so ridiculously slow
and the challenge is it's consistently
slow so if we look at metrics for
example this is the right one of course
it unloaded if we look at metrics once
they actually load we will see that
girls go back sprays you would have seen
that the services were basically
consistently so everything is slowed
down to this application so even looking
at distributed metrics where you've
captured latency from every node of the
system whether it's the catalog service
of the front end service or others
they're all equally slow and so metrics
aren't really going to be able to help
you to diagnose what the problem is so
instead we can jump to stackdriver trace
so stackdriver trace is a distributed
tracing solution for those who don't
know what distributed tracing is we're
able to capture a request as it comes in
to your first sort of front end edge
services and then we track that request
as it goes to any any sub services as it
propagates so in this case for example
it hops from the card endpoint goes to
the currency service and hopes the cart
service into recommendations and then
finally several times to the product
catalog service and the shipping and
currency and so on and so we can see
this request as it bounces around the
application we can see two things in
particular that are probably really bad
the first is it goes to the product
catalog service a lot right so when are
we getting details on a single product
it doesn't really make sense that we
would continually call the product
catalog database to find out details
about that product that should be cached
or frankly it's probably just poorly
written it is poorly written and it's
just calling it way too many times
instead of just keeping the data in
memory somewhere and so you
this sounds like sort of a maybe a
somewhat contrived example but this is
the sort of thing that we see with our
customers and certainly I've seen myself
as an engineer where when you don't have
these tools to understand how your
application works when you're not
tracking how these requests function
you'll you might not notice that you
know when someone when one engineer was
writing something and needed more data
from the catalog that it's made another
call right and this adds up over time
and you get these sort of monstrous webs
of application topology in ways that no
one expected it to actually function and
that's why you have slowness
even if we had a single call to the
product catalog service
you know most C's are taking well over a
second this one takes basically one
point six seconds and so the web
application would still be too slow
we're gonna dig into the second case we
already know what the problem is in the
first case we know that we know that we
need to reduce the number of calls but
the second case is actually the harder
one to debug where the individual calls
are really really slow and distributed
tracing helps a bit we know that you
know the calls of the catalog are
causing the slowdown that's already
taking us through our first level of
triage that metrics didn't but unless
you added a ton of custom spans this
trace you're not gonna know why it's
slow and understand that we're gonna go
to stack driver debugger or sorry it's
time favorite profiler stack driver
profiler is a continuous production
profiler what that means is that it's
always running in the background on and
off so the so you as a developer it's
effectively always running it turns
itself on and off at various points to
capture profilers or capture profiles
and it has effectively no performance
impact that is also true for trace and
debugger but unlike most production
profilers you can leave this one you
spectively just turn it on set it and
forget it
you don't have to worry about you know
running it for 15 minutes 15 minute
sessions or something like that you
don't have to worry about it slowing
down your app profiler captures a number
of things right now we're looking at the
heap view so we're capturing the memory
consumption of every function running on
this service we can also look at CPU
consumption we can also look at how
threads are interacting profiler is
great because it runs on all of the
instances of your service so just like
trace just like debugger you don't have
to point it at a particular instance you
don't turn it on a single instance
there's some kind of canary instance you
simply link it to your code turn it on
and it's running across all the
instances and you're going to see
performance data captured from all of
them this is the heap view we don't see
anything quite too exciting here you
know we can look for the the get product
endpoint which from the trace was shown
to shown to be the slow one or rather
the get product your RPC method which
was shown to be slow from the trace but
this is only consuming you know twelve
and a half percent of the applications
total memory and that's still only about
what 254 kilobytes like this is clearly
not not the source of our problems but
when we jump to see
consumption my water when we jump to CPU
consumption we see that things are
pretty bad so this is the get product
end point it alone is consuming roughly
93 percent of this application CPU just
this one function and you know given
that I've played around the catalog
services code I know that this shouldn't
be the case right it has a number of G
RPC endpoints provider G RPC server
methods that handle handle traffic it
doesn't it doesn't sort of makes sense
that get product he's using so much CPU
but when we look down on this icicle
graph this icicle graph shows
consumption on the horizontal axis and
on the vertical axis we're showing how
these functions actually call each other
we can see that part this calls a method
called parse catalog and parts catalog
is effectively consuming the same amount
of CPU as its parent function so this is
where all the time is spent and this is
where you're both burning money and
burning time and this seems bad right so
next we're actually gonna jump to the
code this isn't this view here is in
cloud source repositories though the
code for this application is actually
stored on github the distinction between
those is kind of irrelevant for this
demo but we're actually jumping to the
code and we can see we're basically just
deserializing a bunch of JSON so what
we've already learned from trace and
profiler in a few minutes is that the
catalog is slow or rather requests to
the website are slow there's flow
because the catalog is slow and the
catalog is slow because this parse
catalog method is spending all of its
time deserializing JSON and that's
probably bad and so as a developer we've
learned something that otherwise might
be very difficult to understand or we
would only know because we have a lot of
existing knowledge of how the system
operates but we've gone through this in
a way that a new developer could go
through it relatively quickly and so
trace and intern profiler have helped us
solve this performance problem quickly
and reliably and we can apply this to
other parts of the system next I'm going
to show you stack grabber debugger in
this case we don't have an error that
we've sort of had time to code into the
application of debug so I'm just going
to give you a demonstration of debugger
and show you why it's useful so
stackdriver debugger as I mentioned is a
production debugger it effectively lets
you set breakpoints in production that
don't halt customer queries this is
pretty magical this is one of the things
when we show it off at our booth or
demos like this we get initially a bit
of skepticism from viewers saying can't
do that that's not possible
but we can and so we present everything
in this really nice IDE like interface
you know it's not wildly different than
like Visual Studio code or IntelliJ or
others and you know you can you can
click in the gutter and and sort of set
a thing that looks like a breakpoint but
what we're doing here is setting
something that we call a snapshot and a
snapshot is effectively a break point
but we don't halt execution so execution
flows right through it but we do capture
the the local variables and we do
capture the stacktrace
and just like a traditional debugger you
can use conditions and expressions I'm
not going to demonstrate those today but
it's got basically the same
functionality that you would expect when
you're debugging something locally on
your laptop or on your desktop and so
I'll show that to you right now we've
got a load test running against this
application and so I don't even have to
open the app to to capture data from it
but if we put a snapshot right here for
example delete that existing one we
think we can see how the code executes
inside of this convert function this
convert function is inside of the
currency service the currency service
will convert in the in the store front
the store front lets you convert from
like US dollars to euros yen and that's
performed by this particular service and
so the snapshot that we laid down is now
being captured at line 123 and we can
see the various objects and things that
were captured from it and so like for
example if we wanted to see the current
if there was some kind of issue of
currency conversion where we thought the
wrong race were being used and you know
we're looking at the input and if
everything seemed right we could
actually go in here and jump to the
currency conversion rates that are being
stored in memory in the service in
production right now right and so we
could very quickly be able to decide if
the rates that are being stored or wrong
or if there's some other kind of problem
occurring similarly we can look at any
of the objects here we can also jump
through call stack and capture the local
variables captured in each of those
frames right so it's just the exact same
power you would expect from a local
debugger except this running live in
production and will not affect anything
so it's really really powerful we use
the same thing at Google with a tool
called bore debugger that's basically
the same really
really nice for solving a rare
production issues
so I'm just gonna sort of double click
on some of the key benefits that we saw
so stackdriver debugger snapshots as
well as a feature and debugger called
log points that allows you to push out
log statements to your application
instantly if they're redeploying it I'll
remove a ton of deployment steps during
root cause analysis like today if you're
developing on kubernetes or some kind of
distributed system and you offering the
production environment where it's either
difficult or just impossible to attach a
debugger you would often solve problems
like this by adding log statements to
your code whenever you've some kind of
error you add a bunch of log statements
to your code to flush out how it's
operating and add things to logs
redeploy your app with the air is still
in tow because you don't know what the
actual errors caused by that can take a
while then you get to read the logs
using your logging tool and find out if
the system is functioning the way you
expect or maybe get some insight into
what the error is maybe you found it
maybe a dad or log statement so you go
through typically a couple iteration
cycles of deploying things to production
which is painful and slow and bad for
your customers with snapshots and then
log points which allow you just add
those log statements if you want the
firehose view you can do that instantly
which is really really powerful this is
why we developed debugger inside of
Google this is why we use it so often
including some of our biggest teams next
we had stack driver profiler so profiler
operates at extreme scale but unlike
most profilers and certainly unlike most
production profilers has effectively no
performance impact it's also not limited
to analyzing single transactions it
gives you that continuous flame graph
view for how your application has been
running in production so it gives you
great insight into the amount of CPU
used by each function of your code as
well as the amount of heat views and you
can also look at threads and contention
and other things like that and so it
gives you a lot of visibility into how
your your core code is running that you
wouldn't have if I were to like
profiling and particularly the heap view
is really useful for detecting things
like slow memory leaks profiler in
addition to giving you that
understanding of how your code operates
is a powerful cost reduction tool so in
the private alpha 4 profiler we had a
number of customers come back to us and
say with about one hour of time they
shaved 10% off their CPU bill without
their compute bill
depending on your scale that might just
be a small amount of money and something
that doesn't really interest you but
once you start running you know a lot of
nodes and your
monthly compute bill is fairly high this
is like really tangible money that you
could save with a very small amount of
time additionally and I'll get into a
minute we had some larger customers who
were fighting performance problems with
some of those services that they were
having to scale way beyond what they
thought was needed and with profiler
they were they were able to get back to
their expected scale by finding in
particular areas of seat high CPU
consumption they didn't expect finally I
showed you stack driver trace tracing is
finally becoming a much more popular
much more well understood thing amongst
the development community which is
awesome but tracing schools tend to
either be expensive or different
difficult to adopt these days there's
certainly open source options Zipkin and
Jaeger are great but you have to go and
manage them yourself and spit up VMs and
certainly manage the storage for them
which can be annoying or sometimes
expensive they're also paid option to
the space they also tend to be
relatively pricey stack driver trace
isn't either of those things it is
simple easy to get started with and
incredibly cheap so I mentioned a
profiler success story so snapchat you
know it wouldn't be a talking next
without mentioning snapchat snapchat was
one of the Alpha customers for stack
driver profiler along with a couple of
other marquee customers they were able
to they used it to find some performance
issues that they hadn't been able to
discover previously you know they left
us this very nice quote about it being
able to pinpoint you know a big big
consumers of CPU time and at snap scale
you know certainly very large they were
able to both reduce their spanned on a
number of services and increase their
overall performance so for them it was
incredibly powerful we had similar
stories come from a number of our other
alpha clients as well as certainly now
the profile was kind of public beta
we've had even more so that wraps up our
tour our whirlwind tour of stack drivers
APM tools I didn't I didn't do a demo of
things like stack driver monitoring or
stacked drivers new kubernetes
monitoring tools there are a number of
other talks happening on those but what
I really wanted to show is how the same
workflows that we have at Google to both
reduce latency of our applications as
well as find the cause of errors can be
a how you can apply those at your own
companies you know over the
in the coming years we're gonna have
even more launching in this space but
even today we've externalized enough of
our application tooling or enough of our
developer tooling that external
developers can effectively we'll go
through the same workflows as us which
is awesome there was one last thing I
wanted to touch on so stack drivers APM
tools have no limitations on where they
can be used so if you have hybrid cloud
applications things that are running on
premises things that are running on your
laptop even like there's no restriction
on where those were the applications
that are being instrumented where
they're running and so there's no
there's no requirement to like only use
this on GCP resources and that's even
with the pricing plans like szostak
grabber profiler stack driver debugger
currently free dr. upper trace has a
pretty generous free tier and there's a
paid tier above that that's coming into
effect in September but this is all the
same regardless of where your
applications are running and we think
it's a really competitive offering like
if you have stuff that's running just on
another cloud we would love for you to
use our tools would be awesome and we
think you'll get a lot of value out of
it so I promised this talk would be
divided into two parts the second part
is about open census so to give you a
bit of an introduction open census is in
instrumentation project that we
undertook roughly about a year and a
half ago maybe two years ago and it's
basically we've been trying to work with
other vendors so that we can get better
tracing and metrics instrumentation for
our tools and for their tools for those
who aren't as familiar with distributed
tracing one of the biggest challenges in
space for vendors for developers for
everyone else is getting traces to come
out of their apps automatically so I
mentioned before that at Google with
dapper we're able to do this and it's
really powerful both so how we helped us
understand our how our apps are
distributed as well as debug problems
but we can do that because we're running
you know a custom version of the JVM we
have our own RPC library and so we we
can do a lot of things under the hood to
enable this that external developers can
write like most shops aren't gonna go
modify the JVM extensively to go do
things that they want they're not gonna
go build their own RPC system and so
with open census we're trying to make
this ubiquitous to developers outside
the company as it is to Googlers and to
do this we need to go and build
integrations of every single thing that
you have that sends and receives an RPC
or anything that really does
slow-running transaction right so where
we and other vendors have struggled in
the past has been that you need to build
integrations across every language for
HTTP other RPC libraries storage client
libraries
you know things first it's some kind of
slow running process that runs on each
machine for things like Kafka for
basically any sort of client library
anything you interact with from you know
tens or hundreds of vendors and it's
really slow and really painful to build
these and so we thought well that's
silly
so with open census we've gone together
and I'll have the list of vendors in a
minute but we've we've actually
partnered up with a number of other
vendors in the space to go build those
integrations so you can automatically
get tracing metrics out of your app and
then do some basic analysis on top of
those and so it makes it as a developer
it makes it really easy to get started
with these tools whether that's with
stackdriver APM or stack driver
monitoring or with other solutions like
data dog or SolarWinds or a number of
other partners so back to the demo app
and we're gonna do another demo of open
census but this is sort of there's no
lines connecting anything but this is
roughly the the structure of that
hipster shop demo so it's got a front
end service email service currency
service and others and as I mentioned
before the written in go Python note j/s
and c-sharp I listed a database here the
demo that we're using just uses an
in-memory data like just basically
decide a big object in memory as its
database but the hipster shop demo once
it's published externally I think it's
going to connect to some kind of sequel
database and so just like any other
customer application you have to have
integrations for all these things right
if you want even if you're just using
HTTP and G RPC you need to go build
integrations for HTTP and G RPC across
every language right if you're using if
that database there is MongoDB or some
kind of sequel database or something
else in order to get traces metrics from
interactions with it we need to go build
those integration this is again just the
problem that open census is solving I'm
sure you know a number of you from
larger older companies can attest to
like you'll have services running in
probably five plus languages using 10 to
20 different storage technologies that
communicate to each other using various
different RPC frameworks like the real
world up there is a mess developers
software is developed over a very long
period of time technologies change old
code doesn't
get deleted and so in order to make all
these things automatic we need to do a
lot of work to actually make that make
traces and metrics show up so to come
back to what open census is open census
is a collection of libraries that we
publish in a per language basis to
collect traces and metrics we have
support for I'll get the fullest in a
minute but we're targeting support for
Java go node dotnet Ruby Python PHP and
C++ so it's a list of eight languages oh
the open census libraries for each
language have sort of three layers to
them they have the instrumentation layer
so that's the things I was discussing
earlier the automatic plug-ins for
various storage frameworks RPC
frameworks basically anything you want
to capture a tracer metric from they've
API so as a developer you can manually
interact with those you can create your
own custom metrics you can change the
metrics that are being automatically
collected you can add annotations to
traces you can change the trace sampling
policy and so on and finally the reason
that we're even working with other
vendors is this concept of exporters so
exporters are these really small
lightweight pieces of code that allow
you to send the data collected by open
census to your back-end of choice one of
those backends a stack driver one of
those backends is just writing
everything out to logs but you can also
send it to backends like data dog and
SolarWinds and in Stannah and a number
of other vendors in this space and the
nice thing about open census is that the
exporters are really small amounts of
code like if you wanted to support some
new back-end you don't have to go
reimplementation re-implement house
sampling works or contacts propagation
for tracing like any of these really
complicated things you just write a bit
of code that translates the data that
opens census has in memory to the date
to the format you expect and send an RPC
to your back-end it's really really
simple and our goal of open census right
from the beginning is to be able to
include as much functionality out of the
box as possible right our the scenario
we want for most developers is you link
and open census library to wrap trays
and metrics come out that's it you
choose next board and traces and metrics
commands it gets into your back-end we
don't want developers to be sitting
there plumbing things and gluing things
together it's really painful it means
that they're not going to use those
tools and quite frankly as a company
that's in the business of selling more
and more distributed systems through
technologies like kubernetes
we want to make this as easy as possible
that's why we invested open census so as
I mentioned before we've support for a
number of languages and integrations and
exporters right now we have really great
support for Java C++ and go for Ruby
Python on PHP the tracing is in a
production ready State and where you've
been adding support for metrics some of
those are a little further along than
others and nodejs I think just entered
in alpha if I remember correctly and so
no GS is is going to jump to full
support pretty quickly as well as Python
dotnet is under development through our
partnership with Microsoft I'll get to
get to that in a minute
but they're gonna be handling
development of net and I think they they
also have a pretty strong interest in
Python note we have a huge number of
integrations far too many for me to list
and certainly far too many for me to
have thrown to this presentation at the
last minute but in general we you know
we support HTTP G RPC sequel you know
sequel clients MongoDB most things that
you would expect to be there if you're
using Open Census and something isn't
there that you expect but you can reach
out to us or certainly we we would love
if you made a pull request the whole
goal this project is getting as many
integrations right into the main client
library so that people can use them out
of the box and so that multiple vendors
can rely on those and rely on and
maintain the same set of integrations
finally we've exporters for a number of
really popular backends we've target our
functionality on open census to always
work for our to sort of reference
backends for tracing and metrics so
Zipkin and prometheus support is always
always there and always guaranteed we
also support Jaeger signal FX data dog
solar winds and Stannah Amazon x-ray and
of course stack driver more and more
backends are being added all the time
with the current architecture of open
census this support these exporters have
to be implemented on a per language
basis and so some languages might have
more support while those others don't at
the end of this presentation we'll talk
about a sort of a new project we're
working on that's gonna expand that
support even further open census also
includes some neat features so I
mentioned analysis earlier so while it's
mostly an instrumentation project open
census also gives you some very sort of
quick ways to understand what's going on
here out
the most prominent of those is something
we call Z pages so if you read hacker
news a lot like I do there was a post
one or two days ago about debugging and
and how we sort of some of the Borg
debugging features used it at Google one
of the things that was mentioned there
and all the top ranked commas talked
about was these sort of Borg status
pages or Z pages and we provide these
through open census to developers around
the world these Z pages are basically
small blood pages hosted by the open
census client library on each note of
your application it shows basic
summaries of the any sort of our pcs
that have been going through the system
as well as summaries of all the stats on
your system so it basically gives you
this little firehose view for the
instance of your app that you're
inspecting it's not necessarily as
useful as looking at something like a
distributed tracing back in like
stackdriver trace which shows you the
end-to-end view these would only show
data captured from a single node but if
you think that something is wrong of a
particular node or if your debugging
process starts with inspecting a single
node these e pages are a great place to
go find that data one of the other
interesting features we have is our work
on the w3c trace context format so about
a year and a half ago Google and Zipkin
started work on this sort of a shared
context propagation format for
distributed traces if you're familiar
with distributed tracing you might
already be aware of this but one of the
challenges in this space is if you're
using different client libraries Edition
its frameworks traces still won't always
work together and so take an example of
HTTP if I have service a service being
service C in order to get its
distributed trace my distribute tracing
system has to know that a single request
is correlated and so you know in dipkin
uses for example to be three headers
that basically set a trace ID for this
trace we started this project with
Zipkin and now a number of other vendors
including Microsoft and others to
basically help snap align everybody onto
the same context propagation format if
you're sort of using a single vendor
system this probably doesn't interest
you as much but it's another way that
we're able to work better with the
community it's really nice
finally a neat thing of open census
assist that you can use multiple
exporters at once
so you can send traces and metrics to as
many backends as you like you know for
example we might have customers who do
like some some metrics to Prometheus and
some go to stackdriver right or rather
all go to both but but if you're either
transitioning between using different
vendors or you're at some kind of mixed
mode environment where different teams
use different systems which is actually
relatively common open census will
support that so if you know some company
gets acquired comes into your company
they're using a different set of tools
as long as you're using open census you
can send a telemetry to all of those
tools and satisfy everybody which is
really great all right so once again I'm
gonna hop over to my demo so inside of
this application I've gone and we've
gone and already added open census to
the services so I'm gonna pull up the
code for the product catalog service and
so we're using open census in the
product catalog service in order to
capture traces and metrics and most the
code is captured here like just like I
described this is a this is a really
nice scenario where you just basically
initialize the open census service
choose an exporter and it captures
effectively everything you want
automatically in this init tracing
function we register open census we tell
it to use the stackdriver exporter and
we tell it to do that for both tracing
and stats and that's about it
I think we also might mention that we're
using G RPC beyond that open census will
automatically go an instrument G RPC
it's going to capture application level
metrics so things like latency and
packet search so we've got packet size a
request size and queue length and others
and it's also automatically going to
capture distributed traces and propagate
context and we saw that mistak driver
trace view and now i'm gonna go try and
open the metrics view to show you the
example that here we go
so these are the metrics captured by
open census this is inside of
stackdriver
this is not work and it's going to
capture it's showing us the latency
of our application here we go the server
license latency and we're gonna grip
this by the different server methods so
we can see the latency across each
server method and let's look at the 95th
percentile there we go oh I see the
primary screen it's just to Zermatt Oh
anyways I can click on these if the
screen was at higher resolution you
would see the various Layton sees 95th
percentile latency for each of the
different services contained in this
application so it's just a with five or
six lines of code I'm now able to get
latency metrics from all the different
methods handled on this single service
right
once I roll this out across all those
services in my application I now get to
understand the latency latency
characteristics of every single every
single endpoint attached every single
service which is really really nice and
of course we already saw the traces but
I also mentioned that open census does
custom metrics and so in addition to
automatically capturing these metrics
you as a developer can go and add your
own so what we had added here I think to
the cart service or the checkout service
was the ability to see how many ability
to see how many checkout requests are
going through the app and so I've done
that here
here we go
and so in the code which we'll show you
in a minute we're capturing the number
of items in a cart when the card is
checked out and we can see the results
here and the code for this was pretty
simple so we've registered the view up
above that's this is sort of how we
create our new metric and then all we
have to do is scroll down to the code
where we actually capture it which is a
single line here it is and if this
single line of code in addition to the
few that register the view I've been
able to capture custom metrics from my
application and I can send it to the
backend of my choice which is great
right you could send this to Prometheus
you can send us the stack driver you can
send us the data dog wherever you really
want it to go and it's not much work
it's both a great developer experience
if you're using a single back-end you
can roll this out across your entire
application but it's a great developer
it's an even better developer experience
if you're working with multiple back
into the mixed-mode environment and so
like I mentioned before our goal of open
sense is to make as much of this
automatic as automatic and as easy as
possible and I think of this demo we've
achieved that so I mentioned some really
interesting features that are coming to
open senses the first is just more
integrations so today we've got a pretty
big list that we're quite proud of but
as time goes on we want to add the
ability to get more traces and metrics
automatically from more and more
different stacks so for example like
today I don't think we support Google
pub/sub or Kafka we're gonna be adding
that we're gonna be adding it for you
know as many technologies as possible
the next that's really interesting is
this thing we call the open sentence
collector service and smarter sampling
so one of the challenges of distributed
tracing today is that requests come into
your application they get traced and
typically you sample those with like a
1% rate or something like that the
problem of this is that the average
request isn't very interesting right if
you think of the average request it goes
to an e-commerce back-end or even to
Google it's probably you know boring it
sits around the 50th percentile if
you're trying to analyze latency it's
not especially useful typically you want
to look at requested or either
correlated of errors or requests that
are slow right in your 95th percentile
latency 99th percentile latency this is
of course very challenging because to
when you make a sampling decision on a
request you usually do that when it
arrives and whatever pass comes in you
don't really have a great way for
[ __ ] whether it's gonna be slow or
not what we're doing what we find to do
is built this a service you can deploy
within your application traces and
metrics from all of your nodes or sent
to that service and then we can make the
sampling decision later and so the
sampling decision will be made on this
service and then the trace isn't the
traces will be sent to your back-end and
so for example you could configure it to
sample traces that have something like
90 99th percentile latency 95th
percentile latency traces for requests
that are relatively uncommon basically
traces that are far more interesting as
an application developer this means
you're actually getting actionable data
instead of spending all of your time and
money on collecting traces that are
frankly not that useful and so this is
like a big big thing that open sentence
is going to provide soon next after that
is providing support for client
applications so one of the challenges of
tracing solutions today or at least some
of them including stackdriver is that
they don't support they don't really
give you true end-to-end latency you can
see the latency of an operation that
occurs inside of your web application or
inside of your data center or inside of
Google Cloud for example but typically
you're not getting visibility into the
actual latency perceived by a client
whether that client is a front-end web
application or their clients like an
Android or iOS app and so we're gonna be
adding support for those no consensus so
we can capture traces all the way from
like your users interaction with with
some of their software all the way to
going to your back-end and then back and
so instead of seeing that a user
interaction took 200 milliseconds and
wondering why your customers say that
your app is slow you can actually see
you know that it's taking two seconds
because of some kind of network issue
between their app you know some iOS app
and and your back-end application and
finally we of course are looking to
expand the list of partners that we work
with for open census and to that end you
know this certainly this is sort of the
big players in the ecosystem there are a
ton of other contributors typically just
open source contributors not working for
a particular company open census of
course started at Google we are the main
contributor we effectively run the
project but in the last few weeks or
months we've also gotten a lot a lot of
support for Microsoft signal FX and
pivotal pivotal in particular right now
is maintaining a fork of
consensus that basically a.net copy of
of open census Java and we're they're
working with Microsoft right now and
turning that to an official open census
for dotnet library signal effects we've
been talking to a lot about the
co-developing that open census service
and they've made some other
contributions to libraries so we're
really excited about that
SolarWinds data dog and in stone i have
all provided exporters and with any luck
they'll move up the list and become core
contributors but we're also just you
know really excited to have them
involved to any degree i we are always
looking to grow the tent for open
sentence whether that whether you are a
you know individual open source
developer and there are many many of
them working on the project as well or
you work at another vendor in the space
we're really excited to work with anyone
like really and so we're we're really
proud of the progress we've made in a
fairly short period of time and
attracting some big names of groups that
share our vision and want to make
tracing and metrics and just generally
observability more accessible to
everyone and so hopefully when we show
this next year will be an even even
bigger list alright I think that's it
thank you very much for coming thank you
very much the stage yeah
[Music]